pictures they make these days all in TV
cut cut cut cut the opening shot of
Rawls's Touch of Evil was six and a half
minutes long six and half minutes Walter
a three or four he way set up the whole
picture that one track shot that father
was the key grip finish
hey what about absolute beginners and
that was an extraordinary shot the hell
was that never heard welcome to now you
see it aren't long takes awesome I'm
talking about the huge ones the
masterpieces where all the technical
camerawork special effects and carefully
choreographed movement pushes the
boundaries of cinema as an art form and
leaves us thinking holy shit
if you want to read more about how
awesome they are I recommend these three
articles or even these ten how about 25
what I'm saying is we're all well aware
of how long takes work
they dazzle they entertain they push
film to its limits but I want to make a
quick video essay that explores one way
long takes might be limited in their
storytelling abilities to start let's
hear from someone familiar who doesn't
like long takes I don't know why I
really indulge in the stunt I can only
call it a stunt in rope rope was
Hitchcock's attempt at a movie taking
place in real time in one long take
originally a play Hitchcock kept every
action and reaction in the frame and let
the camera roll cameras at the time
could only film 20 minutes per reel so
he had to hide cuts in between scenes
when he needed to what are you worrying
about Phillip
after all the result is something
Hitchcock didn't think was all that
great he comments on what it was missing
in a French interview with Truffaut
which explains the French translator in
the background when I look back of
course in the novelty sheets it's quite
nonsense Maurice McMorris Joe Cosley
I was breaking all my own suppose it
took a couple traditionally until film
gonna sell your decision and the cutting
of film to tell story Oh a lot of people
think the cutting is will say montage or
assembly he's taking a man from one
place to another and jumping into a
close-up of him which Griffith invented
is true but to me goes much deeper so
that's what long takes can miss editing
in many ways Hitchcock was simply
filming a play but even with something
originally a play you can use editing to
tell a story and Hitchcock thinks
editing is a strong storytelling device
that was missing with his movie how
could rope have used editing to tell its
story 12 Angry Men originally a teleplay
and then a stage play also has a limited
set and heavy dialogue but the editing
tells us everything
unlike rope which has no ending the
beginning shots are wide and comfortable
there's actually a six-minute long take
in the beginning where conversation is
light and everyone
at ease in the early scenes most of the
dialogue features multiple people that
takes our relatively long and shots of
single people aren't too close as the
movie progresses intense scenes have
super close-ups of characters and the
edits are much quicker by allowing the
camera to cut quickly from close-up to
close up editing showcases the intensity
of the scene
what do you want I say is guilty not to
mention the eerie overhead lighting the
performances and the rain in the
background the cuts are very important
here to quickly and efficiently move
from the action to the reaction as
opposed to a long take where the camera
has to either whip around or we see
action and reaction at the same time
which gives them both equal weight to
the viewer but that's not to say
filmmakers can't direct our eyes without
using cuts on the contrary directors
guide our eyes with the right lighting
camera movement and frame composition
the University of Edinburgh developed a
visual tools that track eye movement so
they can show people a movie clip and
track what they look at in this scene in
there will be blood the person talking
is important to the viewer according to
where they're looking
but eye movement also shifts when
someone moves to smoke a cigarette or
starts leaving the frame there's lots of
ways to direct the eye like what's in
focus where everybody is looking lights
and geometry you may not notice it
consciously but directors are telling
you where to look especially in flashy
long takes the long battle scene in the
revenant is chaos but it's directed
chaos you look from one person to
another or at that specific arrow
whizzing past the camera but according
to Hitchcock a long take just can't beat
the intensity speed and storytelling
power of an effective cut cocktail
implies severing something it really
should be called assembly when clips are
assembled together through editing they
create a new story for the viewer
if you cut from one clip to another your
mind associates the clips with each
other and creates the idea of course the
classic example is the psycho shower
scene but it works in a variety of
movies in The Godfather Coppola cuts
from the spiritual cleansing of Michael
son through baptism to the violent
cleansing of mafia leaders one cleanses
with holy water the other with blood
and all this works you could write a
book on what this editing choice means
in the context of the film but one thing
is very clear the editing is what
establishes this symbolic connection and
a long take just doesn't have the
ability to thematically associate to
different ideas in a way as effective as
these edits montage means the Assembly
of pieces of film which moved in rapid
succession before the I create an idea I
love long takes anybody can appreciate
them for how beautiful they are but they
are limited in their storytelling power
they give us more choices in what to
look at compared to cutting from face to
face or object to object this has its
advantages with more to look at we can
be more overwhelmed more taking it back
more amazed but a cut forcing us to look
at one thing that can be intense has the
kind of emphasis a Big Shot doesn't have
so sometimes an edit works sometimes
along take works it just depends on how
you look at it what's the difference how
long it takes suppose we do it in five
minutes so what let's take an hour ball
game doesn't start til eight o'clock if
you wish this video was longer you're in
luck because all-time movies has a great
video that focuses on how directors pull
off these intricate long takes and
sometimes long takes are hidden in plain
sight
watch Tony's Al's video on the Spielberg
one or to learn more about that both
these videos are in the description
thanks for watching